you mentioned gotch
you uh consider yourself
a catch uh wrestler
uh so i've mentioned to you offline that
i competed in a couple of catch
wrestling tournaments
uh can we go wikipedia level at the very
basic you're the exactly right person to
ask
what is catch wrestling and what are its
defining principles
i would say the easiest way for us to
talk about and
give uh an overview of what catch is
in the simplest terms is think of
collegiate wrestling with submissions
that is essentially what catch is and
it's not surprising because collegiate
wrestling is actually derived
from catch's catch can it's just that
over time
certain aspects were were
removed from the competition structure
so that they became
null elements things that were discarded
but it's funny that you can take
high level uh amateur collegiate types
and you can show them a move and then
add a little bit to it and go oh well
hey that was just like
what we already do here but except oh i
didn't know you could take it all the
way to this point or
you know things of that nature
especially when it comes to professional
wrestling like uh teaching people like
no
that that i know you're just using this
for in a show but this is actually a
real move and here's how it really feels
and so collegiate wrestling and
wrestling in general for people who are
not aware is basically
two people starving their feet and
that's a score
that they're trying to take each other
down and they have to um
they score points along the way you can
end matches by
pinning them for example on their back
i think one way to describe wrestling is
uh
it's very much about figuring out ways
to establish
control and leverage in these kind of uh
tie ups or there's different styles
where you can do more from a distance to
where it's more about the timing and all
that kind of stuff
ultimately it's an art of like both
upper body and lower body and you could
choose the different puzzles that you
solved there
you could be attacking the head the arms
you could be attacking the legs
there's also part of collegiate
wrestling that's on the ground that has
more
uh what's called like a referee's
position right the referee's position
where you're on
uh your hands and knees basically and so
uh
do you do do you understand what that's
supposed to simulate why is that one of
the standard positions it's one of the
standard positions because
one it's one of the easiest ways to
actually get up um
but two it's because you cannot be on
your back if you're on your back you're
getting pinned
and back exposure or
being pinned is pretty much the
universal
wrestling thing one taking the guy
from their feet to the floor and two
pinning them as you go from like was it
uh
cornish wrestling turkish oil wrestling
mongolian sumo uh
indian well they'll call it pelhani it's
also called kushti
um jitsu judo
um so many of them is like there's a
usambo even if it doesn't end the match
it's still like one of the most
important
aspects of the competition itself across
oh so whatever style and this is where
submission like catch wrestling
or uh submission wrestling or jiu jitsu
feels different which it seems like for
most wrestling for a lot of wrestling
the dominance
is the is the goal as opposed to
submission which i i guess those are two
are related but
dominating the position so that's what
pinning is it's almost like
breaking your opponent
like breaking uh through all of their
defenses to where they're completely
defenseless and you could do anything
with them that you want maybe
that's a wikipedia definition of
dominance i don't know
and then yeah i mean it sounds very much
like uh chained to a radiator yeah
yeah yeah uh there's a threat that
connects all partners
uh but submission feels different uh
i mean it is actually different when you
think about it across the landscape
i don't think radically different but
distil slightly different in that
um if you think of wrestling as being
derived from
from from combat right so well it is
combat sports but
more more lethal combat getting somebody
off their feet and onto their back
is this about a lethal a place for the
person on bottom to be
in general i mean i i don't
don't come at me with your talks about
your worm guards
and blah blah blah and whatever spider
bear
okay get out of here with that this is
we're not talking about you
in this highly uh regimented sporting
environment
we're talking about general you know all
the body hair
none of the waxing human beings so um
getting someone on their back okay
they're how
you guys you're trying to get up you're
getting hit with a rock or stabbed or
what have you
set on fire who knows
generally these conflicts are not just
isolated to
on one you it's if it's four on two
you're you're
you're your buddy that was with you back
to back now he's on his back
what do you think now it's going to be
one on one well three go on one
so and then you go you elevate this to
to armored combat right
and it's boom put them on the ground oh
crap it's hard to get up well while
you're struggling to get up stab
you know that's where jiu-jitsu's uh
concepts come from with all their
leveraging and off-balancing is
oh man if i end up in this situation in
tight close quarters combat yes we could
fight it out with
swords and knives and what have you but
it's way easier if
the first thing i can do is foot sweep
you on your back
and then pull my knife and just go stick
you